One of the things that's really struck me about intellectual life is how often
we get the questions wrong and we often get them backwards,
not just wrong,
but actually backwards.
So as a clinical psychologist,
I've often treated people with anxiety and uh,
people wonder practically individually,
clinically,
why are people anxious?
And I think that's a completely ridiculous question.
It,
the reasons for anxiety are starkly self evident.
What I wonder is why aren't people terrified out of their skulls so badly every
second of their life that they can't even move?
Yeah.
And you all laugh because you understand that it's like anxiety.
That's no mystery.
It's like brief spells of calm.
That's a mystery.
Okay.
Client will come to me and say,
well,
I'm procrastinating.
Why do I procrastinate?
It's like,
no,
that's a stupid question.
It's easy just to sit there and do nothing.
What's the mystery is why you ever get up and do anything difficult at all?
Procrastination is the default.
And psychologists ask,
doctors ask,
well,
why do people take cocaine?
It's like,
no,
no.
It's the wrong question.
The right quest.
It is.
Why not like an addicted rat?
Don't you just take cocaine all the time until you die.
That's the quest.
And this question about meaning is like that too.
Is there meaning in life?
That's a stupid question.
It's,
I'm,
I'm serious about that.
That's not a question you ever ask yourself if you're in pain,
right?
Because when you're in pain,
you know that life has a meaning.
It's the pain and you can't argue yourself out of that meeting.
And so when we're asking whether or not life has meaning,
that isn't what we mean.
What we mean is in the face of life's pain and suffering,
does life have any positive meaning?
And that is not the same question.
Now,
when you leave that aside for a minute,
and I'm going to tell you a little story,
a little experiment.
I remember in 1989 when the Berlin wall fell down,
there was a great celebration in Berlin and the Berlin Philharmonic Orchestra
played a part in it and they came out to a section of the wall that had been
knocked down where there was a huge crowd and played ninth.
And I remember watching that,
the great third movement,
the triumphant third movement,
and it was so wonderful to see everyone there and here this orchestra
playing those unbelievably remarkable notes in triumph that this horror show had
finally come to a halt.
You can imagine someone
critically minded and rational and an event like that standing behind you as
you're listening to the great strains of that symphony manifest themselves,
tap you on the shoulder and say,
well,
you know
that's symphony is going to end.
What makes you think it has any meaning at all?
It's like,
well,
how do you respond to something like that?
You say you should reconsider the way you're looking at the world,
their buddy,
because that's just not the right answer.
It's just not the right question.
It's like the symphony has no meaning because it ends well.
You're not paying attention to what's going on.
If that's the way you think or maybe you're thinking too much.
Yes,
you're thinking too much and not paying enough attention and that is more
serious than that and this ties in the issue of pain.
Say What does it all matter?
If in 10 billion years the earth is going to fall into or this sun is going to
expand and consume the earth,
what difference does it make?
And I would say,
well,
is that that kind of answer you're going to give to a child that's in pain?
That's your answer.
It's like,
Hey,
you've got the flu.
You're anxious,
you're having a nightmare.
You're in terrible pain,
but in 10 million years,
who the hell is going to know the difference?
Yeah.
Right.
No kidding.
It's like you don't.
Yeah.
If the question is,
if that response is observed in that situation,
then it's an absurd response.
The mere fact that you can come up with a timeframe across which your current
activity is meaningless only means that you're capable of playing with meanings
across timeframes.
It doesn't mean anything at all about meaning.
As far as I can tell,
is it absolutely obligatory that everything that's meaningful has to be
significant in some unimaginable distant future?
Why is that the hallmark?
Why would you just say,
hey,
here's an idea.
Why don't you stop conceptualizing your life across tight timeframes that takes
all the positive meaning out of them.
How would that be for his suggestion?
Maybe the fact that posing the question in that way makes you feel miserable and
wretched and few tile is an indication that there's something wrong with posing
the question in that manner.
And you might say,
well,
there's nothing wrong with posing questions.
And I would say,
well that brings us back to the child in pain problem.
Sometimes there is a problem with posing questions in a certain way and what
difference is it gonna make in 10 million years is not a sufficient
response to someone who's suffering.
And then you might say,
well,
we could,
we could expand that idea.
Even we could take play with that idea of suffering.
We could say,
well,
maybe it's a child in Auschwitz,
you know,
and this suffering isn't merely a consequence of an illness.
Not that that's trivial,
but the suffering is the consequence of conscious malevolent.
How about that?
And the purpose of the malevolence is just to make things worse.
And,
and to top it all off because malevolence is a form of art.
It's not only to make things worse,
it's to make things worse in the worst possible imaginable way,
which is basically to amplify this suffering of someone maximumly innocent in
the most pointless way possible.
Well,
what,
what's your answer to that?
It's like
10 million years.
What difference is it going to make?
Life is fundamentally meaningless.
It's like what kind of answers that
it's an answer that shows that the framework within which that question is
generated is invalid.
That's what kind of answer it is.
All right.
I realized a while back that I had gone through a process when I was in my
twenties.
It was akin to something Descartes did.
I'm not trying to compare myself to Descartes.
Um,
but he was,
he was trying to look for something that he couldn't doubt and the consequence
of his search was,
I think therefore I am,
which I don't think is exactly a good translation of what Descartes meant.
I think he meant something more like I can't dispute the reality of my own
consciousness.
Something like that.
And that's good.
That isn't where I got to in my contemplations.
I was looking for something that I regarded as in controvertible and I was
fortunate at that time because I was reading Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn,
Solzhenitsyn Road,
the Gulag archipelago among many other things.
The Gulag archipelago is a description of the absolute catastrophes of the
Soviet state and the entanglement of the individual psyches of the Soviet
citizens in that catastrophe descent into deceit and cruelty to seat resentment
and cruelty when Solzhenitsyn,
the Gulag archipelago that he thought the Nuremberg trials were the most
important event of the 20th century.
And the reason he said that
was because the Nuremberg judgment for better or worse,
was that there were some acts that were so viciously brutal that there was no
excuse whatsoever for engaging in them,
no matter who you were or what your culture was or what your rationale was.
And so for,
for soldier,
an incident,
the Nuremberg trials established what you might describe as the transcendent
reality of evil.
And that's an unbelievably useful thing.
It's akin to this idea of suffering in my estimation because,
well,
it's the child in there in Auschwitz problem that
you need an answer
to the problem posed by the suffering of innocence
as a consequence of malevolent.
You say that's,
that's a,
that's evil.
The conscious exaggeration of unnecessary suffering and that gives you a vantage
point that's wrong.
Whatever it is that is,
that's wrong.
Well then you have
a place to stand.
You can say,
oh,
okay,
now I know that there's something that's wrong and now non trivial way in a way
that tech can't be just dispensed with,
with rational objections
that emerge as a consequence of contemplation of the boundedness of life.
Those answers aren't serious enough to address the issue.
Well.
So I thought,
okay,
well I found something that I can
grip onto or stand on without dispute.
There are acts that are unquestionably evil and that means that there are acts
that are unquestionably good.
Now,
it doesn't mean that we know what they are,
right?
Because just because you know one pole of something,
it doesn't necessarily mean you know.
The other.
I could say that whatever leads us as far as way as we can possibly get from
Auschwitz,
that's good.
Well
are being turned to puzzle out what that might be for 25 years.
To outline it in a practical manner,
I suppose in an abstract manner,
to understand if there's a root,
a mode of being,
let's say that takes us away from undue suffering,
but more than that takes us away from undue suffering multiplied by malevolence.
He said it's a fundamental existential problem of life.
We all suffer.
That's the meaning of life.
The suffering is exacerbated by the malevolence in our hearts and the
malevolence in the hearts of all of us
and the paramount issue that faces us is what to do about that,
and the answer is I think
live a life that manifests itself as meaningful because it seems to me that the
meaning isn't a rational phenomena.
It's not something that you create.
This is where Nietzsche,
I think got it wrong.
He believed that as a consequence of the death of God we had,
we would have to create our own values.
We would have to become gods ourselves,
so to speak.
Okay.
But I don't think that Nisha was right because I don't think that we can create
our own values.
I think that we have to discover them.
And I think that what we discover,
our eternal values,
and I think that the eternal values that are discoverable are precisely the
values that lead us away from the pathway to perdition.
It was characterized by places such as Auschwitz.
And I also think that we all know this now.
It's not that we can't question it because we can question it,
but the questioning is in some sense,
beside the point,
like the person objecting to the Grand Juror grandier of Beethoven's ninth by
pointing out that it's going to end.
The questioning is beside the point.
It's missing the point.
I've studied a variety of great psychologists,
John Piaget and Carl Young and,
and Freud and Carl Rogers,
many of the great 20th century clinicians.
And,
and my stance is that along with the biologists and the evolutionary
psychologists that were,
we're starting to map out the pathway that might be the opposite of the
catastrophic motive being that leads us into pits of hell like Auschwitz.
And that there's something genuinely real about it.
Like seriously,
real,
metaphorically real,
and literally real,
both at the same time that the instinct to meaning that you experience,
for example,
when you listen to something great,
that,
that experience of meaning that overcomes you isn't some EPR phenomena.
It's not something,
some mirror reflection of some more fundamental process,
but that which is more fundamental than anything else
say,
well,
you can't deny that pain is real and suffering is real and you can't deny that
suffering induced by malevolence is the worst of all possible sufferings.
Those are all undeniable as far as I'm concerned.
Those are all meanings of life and the real enough so that if you encounter
them,
like if you encounter true malevolence,
the probability that you'll walk away from it and escape this is very,
very low.
It will damage you psychophysiological and you might never recover.
And that's real enough for me.
Well,
it is.
The path away from that real
is the path that transcends that real.
Maybe it's more real.
That's what I've come to believe as pessimistic as I am about the nature of
humanity,
myself included,
as,
as real as I believe suffering and evil to be.
It appears to me that the mode of being that leads you away from that,
that enables you to bear the suffering with nobility and to be useful to others
who are in pain and to constrain the malevolence in your own heart and around
you.
That that mode of being is more powerful than that which it is set against.
And not only that,
I think that we experienced this.
I think we experienced it.
We just don't notice.
Maybe because we're too busy thinking because noticing and thinking aren't the
same thing we see in our own lives when we're engaged in something deeply
meaningful.
Music is the best pathway to that.
I think it's the most,
it's the most rapid and indisputable pathway to that.
Everyone,
virtually everyone loves music and music speaks of meaning.
It doesn't directly and it shows you what life would be like if it was ordered
and harmonious and you were dancing along with it properly.
It gives you an intimation of psychological integrity,
but you watched your lives day to day,
week to week,
month to month.
You'll notice that there are times when you're so deeply engaged in what you're
doing.
What you're doing is so meaningful in the kind of meaning that announces itself,
not the kind that you're creating,
that life is so meaningful.
You think
this is worth the suffering.
Let me think.
Well that's meaning,
right?
Meaning is what makes the suffering worthwhile.
Is that real?
It's not something you think up.
It's something that you discover and you can watch.
You could see day to day,
minute to minute,
hour to hour,
week to week.
You can see when you're conducting yourself or being conducted in a manner that
allows that meaning to reveal itself in a way that in the moment,
even if you don't notice the conditions of your life,
justify themselves and,
and that's really saying something because pain and suffering and malevolence or
real and for something to justify that it's really something for something to
justify that.
But will you find that you find it in art,
you find it in literature,
you find it in the relationships you have with others.
If those relationships are founded on trust and truth,
you find it in what you say and do.
If what you say and do comes from the heart,
you can experience that.
The price of experiencing it,
I would say is two fold.
You have to take responsibility for being,
you have to do that voluntarily and that means that you have to take
responsibility for the suffering of being an excepted and work to ameliorate it.
And you have to do that voluntarily.
And that's a barrier,
I think very frequently that arguments like,
well,
what difference is it going to make 10 million years in the future aren't hyper
rational objections to the nature of being itself,
but hyper rationalistic excuses for failing to bear the responsibility of living
properly,
moment to moment,
and our tower there.
Okay,
say you have a child who's sick,
maybe one who's been hurt.
You say,
well,
what do you say or do in the face of that?
Well,
you say,
Hey kid,
I'm here with you.
I'm here beside you.
Matters what's happening to you and where to do everything we possibly can to
get through this together.
And if you're lucky,
you get a hug.
And as a consequence of that and you think,
if you don't think that's meaningful,
man,
there's something wrong with your soul and answer.
What the hell difference is it gonna make in 10 million years?
That's the devil himself speaking.
Oh,
that's good enough.